time now for a trip back in time as
christoph bauer puts a rare classic from
the 1950s through its paces in 1924 we
didn't grow much set up shop in berlin
has a custom coach builder for
well-heeled customers the post-world war
ii era saw a range of convertibles
four-door taxis and other models based
on the platform of the VW Beetle
Cristo says in 1957 romich promised
drivers that they would like this new
model the Lorenson named after its
designer FET Lawrence and they liked it
big time as its design mirrored the
American styling so popular at the time
but underneath this beautiful exterior
is the VW beetles dependable mass
production technology in tasting hosting
phobic Eva unlike modern cars the beetle
did not employ unibody construction so
once you remove the beetle shell other
bodies could easily be fitted onto the
floor pan
in 1950 rule match presented Tabasco his
first model based on the beetle
throughout 1957 his company turned out
280 units of the hand-built special
edition a sensational success
however in 1955 Volkswagen had brought
out its own sporty beetle derivative and
was keen to see it succeed
common gear by Volkswagen
Christophe says after VW launched the
Karmann Ghia its own sports car based on
the beetle they tried to make life
difficult for even the smallest
competitor including romich Volkswagen
stops supplying him with separate
chassis 'he's having to buy complete
models was far more expensive and
dismantling them was hard work
eventually VW stopped selling him cars
altogether romich had to resort to
middlemen and the black market to get
the beetles he needed Volkswagen was
simply too big to challenge in just the
first year VW made ten thousand Carmen
years while four years production of the
Lawrence amounted to just 85 units
no wonder crafting each individual car
required 1,200 man-hours of Labor
romance succeeded in making a car as
beautiful on the inside as the outside
says christophe luxurious interior
boasts separately adjustable seats and
standard fitted hot air heating with a
window defroster and it has a padded
dashboard a standard safety feature
today but a real innovation back then
the body parts are all made from
lightweight aluminum and sit on a frame
of wood and metal shape of the body
reflects the American Way of life that
was catching on in Europe so this
upgraded beetle from Berlin came with a
panoramic windshield and tail fence
though the lovely looking Lawrence
nonetheless remained a European
everything was a little more elegant and
delicate than the chunkier American
models in fine art see Alicia elegante
as but in diplomacy
the sleek two-tone paint job underlines
the graceful Italian style contouring
and customers could order a color
combination of their choice
designer felt Lawrence was a furniture
maker by trade this beauty would be the
only car he ever created as a favor to
Friedrich well match inside it came
fully loaded with a petrie steering
wheel and details that gave it the aura
of a luxury model the romance warrants
its 15 centimeters lower than the VW
Beetle which Krishna feels gives it a
look that's very sporty and dynamic
unfortunately it doesn't feel that way
to drive and it's fitted with a standard
beetle engine which barely generates 30
horsepower this car has been customized
with two so Mike's 32 carburetors
that's up the output to 40 horsepower
which Christoph thinks is okay that's
this one okay
the souped-up 1.2 liter engine lets the
car hit a top speed of 135 kilometers an
hour 25 more than a standard beetle
Christoph says that the Romish Lawrence
was the last German car to combine an
individually made alloy body with
reliable series production technology so
it's definitely a milestone in
automotive history the Romansh Lawrence
is a relic from the good old days when
cars were handcrafted and manual labour
was still affordable today the 1200
hours it took to produce a single
vehicle would translate to over 100,000
euros and labor costs alone
you